all right well we are just about set to
go tonight colby allard gets to start
tonight for the rangers if you like
round numbers it's 25 games 15 starts
and even
100 innings this season so far for colby
allard
curiel he goes after the first pitch
bouncer right side solax throw in time
good stretch by abanez
and it makes for a nine pitch inning for
colby allen great start bottom of the
first inning it's from valdez on the
mound for the astros 8-4 2.94 era and 16
starts the 0-1
and that's a ground ball softly hit left
side tough play for bregman bare hands
throws to first just in time to get
hernandez bregman's so good at that play
the slow roller coming in
and that is the first out he is ready to
play comes charging in after a quick
jump on that swinging bun
off the bat of hernandez fortunately
playing in a little bit closer than it
normally does in a matches from super
bowl you see the bare hand grab and
throw with velocity to get
yani hernandez by quite a bit too out
nobody on for doley's garcia
oh yeah probably valdez drops in the
hook to get adolesce garcia and a strong
inning to start this one we're scoreless
after one jordan now has played in 200
career major league games
1-1 pitch sent high in the air pretty
deep to center field back to varus to
the wall good home run jordan alvarez
adds to that total in game number 201
the bench celebrates a shot to straight
away center that tavares said he just
missed catching
big man with a big swing early on it's
good to see the astros get on the board
early against colby allard barreled by
yard on 106.3 miles an hour off the bat
it was just a matter of when it was
going to come down unfortunately it was
right after
that 407 mark bregman three for eight
that's coming off the aisle with that
quad injury
down and in bregman on base for a third
consecutive time going back to last
night he's a one out base runner last
time when allard faced the astros tuck
had the big blast did not allow a run in
either outing there is a line drive over
the head of the shortstop isaiah kinder
philippa and tucker on the first pitch
has a base hit into left center the
astros with runners on first and second
and one out
aldonado oh for three yesterday but he
drew a big walk right in the middle of
that five run rally in the seventh
inning
aldonano smokes one in a left center
field that's a huge hit down in the
count bregman scores and comes kyle
tucker astros lead three to nothing on a
two rbi bullet by martine maldonado you
can see the reaction from colby allard
knowing that he made a bad pitch and
martine made him pay
maldi knows how important that one was
rbi's 31 and 32 on the year one out
nobody on for andy abanez
and there's a big swing and a miss and a
strikeout for fraumber valdez who picks
up his second strikeout
as the hot hitting of bonies goes down
swinging they will start the third the
same way they did the second that is
jordan alvarez
one two for mallard and a swing and a
miss he got alvarez
and that's out number one correa flew
out to deep center his last time up
correa drills one to left field forget
about it second deck shot out in a hurry
carlos correa number 20 on the year and
the astros lead this game four to
nothing wow the ball was smoked 111.3
off the bat into that second deck
at globe life field and coming into this
game the astros only had one home run at
this ballpark in the three pre four
previous games now they've got two in
this ball game before seeing fastball to
carlos middle in
and he absolutely clears the front side
and barrels it up and so one pitch and
one out for yo helpozo to call it quits
the 1-0 that one is ripped up the middle
in the center field to base it so first
base hit for the rangers here this
evening is a yohel pozo line drive
single
and the rangers have a man on with one
out how to bring up leotis tavares
center fielder looking for a ground ball
here's the pitch
and he got him strike three he'll take
that
his third strike out of the game comes
on another curveball two outs now runner
on first base for yani hernandez
there's the curveball swinging strike
and from valdez works around the first
hit of the night for the rangers one man
left on base we're through three with
the astros leading four to nothing
isaiah connor felefa up to the plate
trying to get this offense going and he
is riding a nine-game hitting streak
make them necessarily the way he's used
to and so that's something he's had to
overcome
a little tapper down the line and connor
falefer reaches as the ball gets away
he'll turn and head for third tucker up
throwing and isaiah all the way to third
base but he's going to be out
i had a feeling that was coming
unfortunately for isaiah kind of falafel
you see runners do this so often
and it's just kind of a habit where they
don't run in that running lane if the
ball hits you when you're not in the
lane you're going to be out and he's not
in it
1-0 he swings and that one is shot
through the right side vacated with
three infielders on the left it's a base
hit for adolescent
pitch and that's low ball four so
a single hit batter to walk and the
rangers have a little something going
valdez with the bases loaded working out
of the wind-up
1-1
[Applause]
chopper right side altuv at his second
one on to first not in time it gets a
run of the plate
0-1 and that's hit hard and a diving
grab by bregman on the hot shot by the
ohel pozzo he's been tested with a
couple of baseballs charging in and then
he's got a hot shot to his right that he
lays out and makes a great play on
three two pitch breaking ball swinging a
miss five strikeouts for fraumer valdez
his first since the last out of the
third here is kyle tucker leading off in
the sixth inning he's one for two with
that single allards total that inning
as tucker sends one deep to center field
well struck going all the way back is
garcia and he does not make the play
looked like he got there and didn't
quite finish off that play as it bounces
over the wall in the bullpen for a
double well two they owe for two with a
walk
[Applause]
on the ground deep short long throw
kinder pelefa altuve is safe the ball
goes past the first baseman of banyas
astros at a run
it is now five to one
hustle base hitting rbi it was a good
job by connor falefa to get there but as
he took a couple more steps to set his
feet for that strong throw altuve has
already passed the bag as bonnie has
tried to stretch out there and pick up
that out garcia singled
through on the right side and scored the
ranger run in the fourth inning at the
trade deadline the 1-1
and garcia shoots that one deep out into
right field it's gone
and adolesce garcia
does it again to the houston astros
28th home run of the year and it's five
to two this is something ranger fans can
get used to you mentioned this damage
against the astros they're pitching
staff
for garcia this looks like a two-seam
fastball trying to go front door at
least leaks back out over the plate
and garcia with that great power to the
opposite field we've seen it all year
long
showing off that strength when he gets
those arms extended he's not afraid to
look the ball travel a little bit
try and pick up a save for the second
straight night is ryan presley see if
presley tries to take him off the plate
here
to ground ball towards third that's a
fair ball bregman's throw across in time
ball game over astros winning for the
fourth straight time to go to 25 games
over 500 that's their high water mark of
the season
and blummer back-to-back wins on this
road trip and a six and a half game lead
now over oakland